[Music]
travis is in fort worth hi travis how
are you
i'm doing all right how about you all
better than we deserve brother how can
we help
well um
my wife and i both have kind of newer
cars
i paid mine off
last
about probably six months ago and
she still has about 6500
we would have had everything paid off
but we ended up both of us had a baby
last february
and um
we
don't we haven't done any payments on in
a while because we've done so many
payments on there and i was wanting to
know if we should
sell my vehicle to pay the rest of hers
off and then have probably about
fifteen thousand to twenty thousand left
over to throw on other stuff
are you out of debt except that
uh yes so my wife just has the 6500 that
she owes left on on the 2019 uh terrain
and
i got a 2017 camaro but you don't have
any other debt anywhere
student loan debt medical debt
credit card debt
we've already paid all the hospital
bills and everything
okay so the only debt in your entire
world is six thousand five hundred
dollars
yep okay and what's your household
income
um
it's about
50 to 60 000.
okay
and you guys are what 24
um where she just turned 28 i'm 27 i'll
be 28 next month and you said you both
had a baby i'm assuming it's the same
kid
yes okay
you said that kind of funny and i
thought
whoa oh
i'm sorry
we had a new child we had a new child
yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay
yeah so what what i uh
all i want you to do is i want you to
get on a written
budget with our every dollar app it's
free to use
matter of fact i'll put you guys through
financial peace university
and we'll pay for it i'll pay for it and
we'll sign you up to ramsey plus
membership which will get you into
financial peace university it'll also
get you on the every dollar app premium
and the two of you you and your wife sit
down now that gift is a hundred dollar
gift if i give that to you you have to
promise me you'll use it okay
yeah we died before but we'll do it
again okay
um well i know you're not on a budget
because you can't tell me how much you
make
so i know you're not getting a written
budget every month
well yeah the reason why i'm saying i
was kind of an estimated because my wife
just started a new job and i kind of
added the numbers before then okay yeah
but your monthly income needs to be
every dollar of your monthly income
needs to be allocated to this and i want
you to roll up your sleeves do you have
any money saved other than a thousand
dollars
um
we got about probably three thousand
dollars now because she was not working
for six months but she's working on her
yes okay you both have a paycheck now
you pay all your bills now take two of
the three put it on the debt that leaves
you forty five hundred you get your 1
000 baby step one now we attack that
baby step two debt like it's a debt like
it's a like you're like a gazelle
running from a cheetah you remember and
you knock it out as fast as you can and
you keep her car
yeah you don't there there's no reason
to sell your car
uh you can you can keep both of them you
need to get them paid off
and then you need to build up your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses with a new baby in the house
and
that is the process
it's funny how the first baby especially
uh changes the landscape of the brain
right
well and he mentioned one thing that i
might consider which is he may be
walking out to that driveway and looking
at a camaro that can't fit a car seat or
something and he wants it to be
it might make him feel noble to sell the
car for his wife but it may also be
that's an impractical fee it was cool
when you're a
high school kid or you're older now or
something but maybe not if you need to
sell the car for other reasons there's
nothing wrong with that right but you
don't have to sell it to get out of debt
no you make enough money pay off the car
the math the math works that's right
yeah it may be time to uh move to a
family car
at this stage of the game i had a camaro
before our kids were born yeah i'm about
sharing a new camaro for christmas
before our first child was born and then
i drove it and totaled it
that is the the most newlywed gift when
you get your wife something that you
really want us a bass boat and a shotgun
it's like a kid buying a tonka truck for
his mother for mother's day yeah it's
like the same thing